no more training and no further matches
for mason greenwood until the
allegations of violence against a woman
are fully investigated
the 20 year old forward has spent four
years at manchester united but the club
moved quickly to suspend him after
multiple allegations were published on
an instagram account
the police confirmed he was arrested and
officers were seen at his home near
altringham in a statement they said
greater manchester police were made
aware earlier today of online social
media images and videos posted by a
woman reporting incidents of physical
violence
an investigation was launched and
following inquiries we can confirm a man
in his twenties has since been arrested
on suspicion of rape and assault
his clubs say that legal process now
needs to take its course and added that
manchester united do not condone
violence of any kind they confirmed
mason greenwood will not return to
training or play matches until further
notice
greenwood has also previously played for
england one of his sponsors nike said we
are deeply concerned by the disturbing
allegations and will continue to closely
monitor the situation
at the center of this is a woman who has
a right to privacy as well as a
high-profile footballer who has the
right to be heard tom parmenter sky news